i
didn't have this lovely gold carpet or
your personality here or anything
um but it was you know it was a room
that i shared with three other women
over the time i stayed there i i was
keeping track of all sorts of things so
you know over the time i stayed there i
had 53 different women that i lived with
that kept coming through coming through
coming through
um
and it was bars so you know i mean it
was not any privacy and then
i sat in the bed and on my bunk pretty
much the whole day we had one hour where
we could go up on the rooftop and they
had kind of an enclosed
cage i guess you could say it had like
chain link fence on the top so we
couldn't escape that way
and um you know you'd get one hour of
fresh air and i started doing yoga up
there
and and
your your two daughters uh they they
were with you their stepfather in a way
in in sweden yeah uh and you got to talk
to them on the phone right yes that was
my lifeline that was absolutely my
lifeline
but they didn't know
no we made a very they didn't know where
you were no not exactly they knew he was
in san diego they knew that part
um
we made a decision because they were so
young that
and we were dealing with so much
uncertainty that it was
a choice that we made to not tell them
exactly that i was sitting in jail
because what do you say to a young child
like that you know
what happens to their values if you say
yeah she's sitting there and um you know
nobody can really help her and it's
taking and obviously we didn't know in
the beginning it was going to take so
long i mean if i'd known that
i don't think i could have made it it
must have been difficult to to
keep this a secret even i mean people
around you must have known people around
him must have known the family family
immediately knew but we we we weren't
going out nobody's telling the children
no
i know it's hard but you've got to think
if we had told them and dealing with
this uncertainty they would have not
felt well they would have not had a
childhood i mean i'm so grateful for
sergio for for giving them the chance to
have a decent childhood and of course
you never knew that it would last for no
of course not
that was what was you know the the part
of the hardest thing of dealing with is
this uncertainty and this
powerlessness of of not being able to
influence or you know i mean you just
had to kind of go through
the motions and every day and get
through it one way or another we're
going to talk about you uh
being released uh and and
seeing your kids again and but first we
got to release her uh
i'm sorry because i they they're kind of
desperate yeah they're i i i know i know
it's you shouldn't
wait
thank you and good luck tomorrow yeah
thank you so much
the the charger finally i i mean and
this is after after almost four years
the charges were dropped yeah
so uh they they did you you were not
extradited and you were they couldn't uh
um uh
charge you for anything uh and
uh and you got to see your children
uh and you must you must describe that
moment i
first you came out you didn't you didn't
go home to sweden immediately right no
my charges had been dropped cases all
closed um it took several weeks for that
information to reach the states
when they got that information they
basically said we need to get her out on
bail right away or bond and so they did
it took about a week to do that and then
they were waiting for all the paperwork
and everything to get an order and it
was in descent it was december 9th
actually in 2009 when i actually got
released out on bond
and um
so i had to stay five weeks more in san
diego before i could actually come home
because i had the final you know waiting
for all the official stuff to get
organized and then then you came home
then i came home how was it to see them
again
it was
unbelievable it was magical it was the
best moment in my entire life actually
um
they i mean just to hold them again you
know that was
it's indescribable it was just
um we surprised them they they said we
don't want to know when you come home we
just want you to be home one day
so you know when my case was everything
was cleared up um you know i took the
flight started who picked me up at
orlando we came home it was in january
so it was you know cold and winter
clothes and stuff
and he called them and said you know
come on home and so they were walking in
the door and they were taking off all
their winter jackets and their boots and
everything and then um
i was sitting in the living room and
there was a wall and so they came in the
entrance here and he was standing there
said he was standing there and he we
were normally talking on skype and he's
like are you ready to talk to your mom
and they're like yeah yeah yeah
and so he said well are you ready to
talk to your mom and they said yeah i'm
wondering why is he asking twice and he
said well
good because she's here come on in and
they turned the corner and then we just
ran into each other's arms and hugged
and cried and
i it's an indescribable moment
in my life and for a whole family did
you ever get the compensation
no um and you know i get this question a
lot and and basically i was under treaty
law so the u.s was just holding me ready
to send me they really didn't do any i
mean they were doing what they were
supposed to do and and you know and
mexico just took time for it to get in
front of the the the judge and
you know get the information there so
nobody owed you the
who you know when i came home after four
years of dealing with so much of that
dark environment and such negativity and
you know all these attorneys i just
wanted to be
peace and just be in a place of very
positive energy and um
you know for me it was a very clear
decision between the fear of the worst
and the love of my family and you know
when all this happened which is what i
was visualizing every single day while i
was there
um i i just i wanted to go forward with
my life and you know
climbing moldova thank you so much thank
you
please welcome karen bordeaux